if you build a website in 2021 you'll  likely use a framework like react  angular review the actual code will be  written with something like typescript  or babel which itself is an abstraction  on top of javascript or ecmascript which  is code that needs to run somewhere  like a browser or nodejs which are  runtimes that rely on a javascript  engine like v8 to create an abstract  syntax tree and compile machine code  which is a set of instructions that can  be executed directly by the cpu which  uses a bunch of logic gates to compute  things and manage memory which are  formed by transistors that use  electrical signals to represent ones and  zeros which is made possible by the laws  of quantum mechanics which is perceived  through something we don't understand at  all  human consciousness